there's lauren tasteless clueless
and completely predictable anna lynn's
first major role was in 2007
in a series called american heiress but
her big break came in 2008
playing naomi clark in the cw reboot of
90210.
fans didn't know it at the time but anna
lynn was battling some serious trauma
during her rise to fame
that eventually led to a recent
diagnosis dissociative
identity disorder disassociative
identity disorder
is was formally known
as multiple personality disorder it's
formerly known that because that is not
what it is
it is actually a fragmentation of the
sense
of self so it often is survivors of
trauma
who typically severe and often childhood
trauma
that end up being sufferers of
disassociative identity disorder
for anna lynn she says that the trauma
started in childhood
with years of sexual abuse she later
uncovered in therapy
for 10 years i thought it was my fault
my body actually
completely shut everything down
and wouldn't let me fight back because i
thought that was the only way to cope
with abuse
according to the national alliance on
mental illness the condition
often develops as a way for people to
deal with intensely painful experiences
the american psychiatric association
explains that patients
tend to exhibit two or more distinct
identities
that come with changes in behavior
thinking and memory
and the way i describe it is it's not
different personalities i'm not british
one day
and you know south african the next i
i am anna lynn but it's it's
parts of analyn are allowed to come out
at this point and they're not
safe to come out at this point or parts
of aniline get triggered
out in the world and come out to protect
let's just talk about how the id
initially showed up in your life
when was the moment where you figured
out okay something's going on here
well it should have been when i was
wearing black wigs and
randomly changing all of these different
parts of myself were coming out and
kind of a carousel of expression when i
was in my early 20s
but now i just thought you know other
people are boring and i'm much more
interesting
yes this is the story i told myself so i
have to do it with a baby voice so that
it sounds nicer and softer to you
or for me to be able to express it or
whatever the case may be and i i had
these different variations what i often
would find myself in was protective mode
with this very masculine energy
this kind of balls to the wall middle
fingers to the sky
in your face situation and that part of
me
was clearly necessary because of all the
things that i went through and now
remember going through as a child
during a hiatus from 90210 in 2012
she jumped into a role on an indie film
called excision
it's not my fault i was born with a
chemical imbalance as anna lynn stepped
into her character pauline
she felt her disorder taking control i
was so good at
slipping on the shoes of anyone but
myself i never wanted to do anything
that was even remotely like me that was
the first time i was
really exposing my nuanced ideologies
and
mindset it wasn't the homicidal side of
her
that i related to just so everyone knows
uh
it was it was this this strange little
girl
that was the first time that did
with my acting actually got all
misconstrued because
i i went into it the shoes of someone
and they were my own shoes
and it was terrifying now that she's
aware of what she's up against
analyn says she's changed the way she
works in the new power prequel raising
kanan
narrated by 50 cent well the new process
requires my whole self
i got to dive in with all of me and we
were in one of those
meetings with the director and the
actors everybody and and we were talking
about
my character tony and and she's
she just owns her sexuality and they
were like oh she's pout you know she's a
power woman
she's hurt how many times do we give our
soul away
right just because all we wanted for a
moment was to feel loved
and that for me was my life because of
all this and now
my whole self knows that my body's a
temple honey
annalynne is giving these words of
encouragement to anyone else who might
be struggling
it's so courageous to be human you don't
have to look at it until that moment
when you're ready
if i if i affect one person then all of
this is worth it
you